what do you make of uh cbs jason lochen
forest saying that
seattle had gotten you know calls for uh
possible
you know trade talks with you do you
believe that
that uh seattle has gotten calls yeah
i definitely believe they've gotten
calls for sure i didn't think that uh
you know i think anytime you're um you
know
you know a player that you know tries to
produce every week and
has done it for you know consistently i
think people are going to call for sure
and i think
it's part of the process yeah but you're
a franchise quarterback you're a hall of
fame quarterback
you're not available are you well i'm
not sure if i'm available or not
that's a that's a question but also i
think more than anything else is um
you know i think the end of the day you
you want to win you know you play this
game every day to wake
up to win you play this game you know to
to be the best in the world you know i
you know what i hate i hate sitting
there watching other guys play the game
i'm gonna tell you michael it just keeps
happening like every
week our resident political scientists
and political analysts become the sports
talking head
because these stories i keep thinking of
you every time something happens jason
i'm like wow wonder what jason thinks of
this
you're making me new bro you make news
hey bro you jason johnson
you're good i mean i mean
are you concerned this is exactly
what i wanted to hear i'm so proud of us
you know like they say real g's moving
silence right he's usually quiet
but he's putting this out there he's
been this is like
this is this is it's like when d wave
was talking about playing with lebron
he's like sometimes the relationship
gets a little stale you got to spice
things up
this is this is you've been with your
partner for a long time and one day they
come home was like
you know who hit on me at the mall today
um
very attractive on the subway i didn't
even know i just i just put this
people are looking for me look little me
russell hall of fame wilson
who's been behind this lousy offensive
line who's gotten sacked more times than
anybody else in the league in the nine
years that i've been in this league
people are looking for me i can't
believe it he
is doing what we have not seen enough
quarterbacks do and certainly not enough
black quarterbacks do throughout their
career is
every time russell wilson from now on
and i'm proud of him for this
every time russell wilson ends the
season and he's not in the super bowl
he's going to put pressure on the
seahawks it's the same thing that aaron
rodgers has done it's the same thing
that tom brady has done
these guys look at tom brady's 43 year
old manga love himself
win a super bowl with a team that at no
point this season did anyone say was the
best in the nfc
he just saw them win a super bowl he's
like what are we doing
what are we doing what's happening here
what's happening here so i'm i'm happy
russell's going to do this he's not
getting traded but i do think this is
putting a fire
under the seat of pete carroll and john
snyder and walden the new offensive
coordinator
the best offseason possible you said
he's not getting traded are you sure
that he's not getting traded are you are
you willing to say that
uh you're confident russell wilson will
be the quarterback of the seattle
seahawks in 2021
i am a hundred thousand percent you can
put this with kurt your enthusiasm use
it
russell wilson will be the quarterback
of the seattle seahawks
old tanks exposed can tweet me russell
wilson
will be the quarterback of the seattle
seahawks at the beginning of the 2021
season
he has a no trade clause so he's not
going anywhere that he doesn't want to
go
i don't think he wants to leave seattle
at all i think i mean they won the
division
they won 12 games the man doesn't get
hurt that often
the rest of the division is basically in
disarray i don't believe in matt
stafford like i said
stafford we don't know who's going to be
the quarterback 39er
right and and i've already told you
that you know kyla murray is the dollar
store version
of of russell wilson so he's got a great
position
now he's shaving dollar stores nice
shaving dollar stores dollar store
versus churches chicken knives dollar
stores bro private schools
private school got you all sedated like
that okay
go ahead michael go ahead yeah
yeah doc dr jason johnson okay okay
life's good for you
all right listen hey oh talking
something else
that i'll tell you mike smith and doc
johnson
uh and mike knows this i'm not always
great look
i i'm a little late i i'm not always on
twitter
so i catch up a little bit late i'm not
on it all the time
but don't you know dr jason johnson
and michael smith mike i don't know if
you saw this
jason johnson trying to do his best mike
florio slash
adam schefter saying you know
sources tell me my sources that's what
he said mike
my sources tell me that if tom
brady had lost the seattle super bowl he
was going to be traded
and jimmy garoppolo is going to take all
that like you're going back
i saw that you digging into your
six-year-old notebook
yes yes i don't know that was in your
book michael holly
i didn't i will tell you all this i
literally spoke to a very well respected
uh sports writer reporter journalist
that you guys know
best selling author we had this
conversation in a green room
and he was he was vociferous and
prolific and saying
had because he found out i was a
seahawks fan so we started having this
whole conversation
and he said had the seahawks we were
talking about dominoes this is two or
three years ago he's like had the
seahawks won that super bowl
brady was out he was like a hundred
percent he's like i can tell you
he was 100 out they were gonna move on
to jimmy garoppolo
brady would have not won a super bowl
for 10 years if you think about it
that seahawks win which really was on
the defense of malcolm butler
that led him on you know another a
second career run
of winning four more super bowl yeah and
he lost to seattle at that particular
point tom brady is gone from the new
england patriots and they'd be
at this point six years into jimmy
garoppolo and probably three
reconstructed needs
so yeah that's that is that is from an
actual
and actual swords in a green room source
back when we used to have groups
well we'll we'll allow it it's from it's
from another reporter we'll allow it
it's fine
it's okay
because it was a green room but yes
well-known i got your
respect i don't trust listen i don't
trust many people's sources but that's
cool
um that's a good story we i do want to
get your thoughts on the most recent
super bowl and of course the impeachment
trial
but just one more thing on the seahawks
so you became a seahawks fan
because of russell wilson correct so
is it like lebron fans who just follow
lebron
wherever he goes so they become a cavs
fan and a lakers fan or they were a heat
fan at one point
so if russell let's say he is the
quarterback this year
and maybe even next year but if he
leaves will you follow russell or will
you stay with the seahawks just i just
want to kind of get that clarification
i will follow both because as you guys
know and as i've said many times
publicly and privately i root for
whichever team has a black coach and a
black quarterback
i was an eagles fan with nab and andy
reed for 14 years
when mcnabb left i was supporting the
vikings when mcnabb left i was
supporting the washington football team
and i was looking for another team when
he left the eagles and i was basically
deciding between wilson and kaepernick
and and i decided russell wasn't i
became a seahawks fan before they went
to their first super bowl
so that's that was that was the sort of
process if russell wilson were to leave
which i don't believe is gonna happen
this year but if russell wilson were to
leave at some point
i would root for whichever team he went
for and i would still be with the
seahawks
because of jamal adams because the dk
metcalf because of tyler locked because
of all those other guys who i support
even with your new best friend i was
going to say yeah jamal adams right
who you
[Laughter]
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe before you leave and be sure
to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you